Beverly's with us in Huntsville Alabama
hi February how are you I'm just fine
how are you
better than I deserve what's up okay I'm
thinking about getting married again
I'm 52 recently probably about two years
now have lost my husband and I'm a
little and the guy that I'm seeing he's
also a liver my question is we both have
401ks I may have about 250 and he may
have about 300 and what we're trying to
figure out is what we should do upon our
death and I have three children grown
living on their own and he has none and
I want this marriage to be different
from my other one I want to be totally
committed totally involved he's a very
good man and and I believe he wants the
same thing I wanted to just go ahead and
leave my 401k or whatever to him and
making sure that you know that his day I
think leave it to my children you know
and I can't guarantee that of course but
he wants to leave his 401 K to his
sister instead of use instead of you yes
what he feels like that his sister has
always had a hard time with her husband
and they had four kids and she's never
worked and she struggles real hard and
he just feels like that she needs it now
with that being said he would leave me
the house the millions when we get
married and he would leave me his
$50,000 life policy but 310 401 K would
go to her
well III that doesn't sound like we're
home
it sounds like you have one plan here's
a different plan it doesn't feel right
it's well I don't know it's my plan is
wrong and my plan is right I'm saying
yeah they're just not equal is what I'm
saying why you're leaving him all your
money but he's gonna give his money to
somebody else if he dies
that just seems that's just--that's that
that doesn't work I mean we either need
to vote neither one of you leave it to
each other or both of you leave it to
each other
okay that's what I want so yeah you're
gonna have to find something in the
middle here or whatever mate maybe he
just leaves her a hundred grand or
something
Rach and maybe you leave your kids a
hundred grand you could do portal
beneficiaries on 401ks okay okay and so
you could leave you know a little gift
to her to his sister upon his death or a
little gift to your kids upon your death
and the spouse gets the balance or vice
versa you could leave a hundred thousand
to him he can leave a hundred thousand
to you and the balance goes to your
children the balance goes to his sister
you know leave the big bigger proportion
to the outsider you know what I'm saying
whatever why we just need to be willing
to do the same thing because I think
that's gonna I mean I might start you
got a big heart you got a real sweet
spirit but I think over time that's
going to grate on you okay
would it would me but I'm not as sweet
as you are but it would me and so um you
know I just I and I just also I got to
tell you - I I don't know what's going
on with her sister but she's not doing
well usually giving her money is going
to help her not do well with on larger
scale so I want to know what why she
hadn't done well and you know are we
really helping her or not I mean he may
have a big heart in a blind eye why and
I don't want to give a drunk a drink
that's starting to bother me in the back
of my mind here I don't know what's
going on but I just always question that
when when you do your inheritance based
on someone's need on the other side
that's I start wondering about that
because see the way I look at this stuff
is the money is not yours and money's
not is its gods you're managing it for
God is that God's plan is that God's
best use of God's money
right and that's the way I start asking
it just because they're not managing
their money and they've always had a
financial struggle because they don't
manage their money and how we gonna fix
that we're gonna give them some more
money to not manage that doesn't make
sense right and that's not good
stewardship that's what I'm starting to
question and I don't know the details
there and I'm not trying to stir up fine
but I just I just want you all to work
through that together and I would
suggest to him that he leave her a nice
healthy gift if he wants to but not the
whole thing and leave you the bulk of it
so something like 100 just say okay her
first hundred thousand goes to her
everything else goes to you same you do
the same first nine thousand goes to
your kids you do and then you'll promise
to leave his portion on to his sister
upon your death you can probably
compromise to leave your portion on to
your kids upon his death if you pre to
cease each other you can do that you can
set that out as a terms in a will you
could even do it in the trust if you
wanted to you can make it even more
strong but if you trust him he trusts
you use and that's fine and you can lay
all of that out the thing is it's just
very very valuable to have a combined
process for handling money together
especially in second marriages okay okay
one thing that I was concerned with as
you get older your health you know you
have to worry about financial aid what
am I gonna have to go through you know
take care of myself for better for worse
for richer for poorer unto thee all my
worldly goods I pledge that's the
old-fashioned Book of Common Prayer
marriage vows right and something must
have happened to me you know he'd
finance what he could need you know that
money let's say you used up all your
money and his money taking care of him
because he got really sick
that'd be called being married exactly
and and you know sister and your kids
are up a creek they gonna have to make
way on their own that you take care of
each other you you know you can't go I
can't spend that money on his cancer
treatments because my kids were supposed
to get that money no and how this works
and I guess that's what I'm holding them
to is in the old fashion and never
really had and what I've wanted so bad
on my life yeah that's called all-in
right right
everybody puts their chips on the table
all in and that's where I want you guys
to be but you could you can custom
design you know predeceasing if
everything's going good let's say his
3-under turns into a million your 300
turns into a million which is pretty
likely to happen if you live up into
your 70s you got it invested well anyway
and you leave her a hundred or leave
your kids a hundred well whoopee you're
both gonna be okay you know
yeah yeah so that that's that's a great
that's a good way it happens but but if
in the next two years one of you becomes
deathly ill and it starts burning money
like nothing then in which hospital
things do that you and I know that even
with health insurance and then you know
your commitment as to him his commitment
to you and you guys got to be real clear
on that that all-in thing I think you're
on to something and I agree with you
okay I appreciate it and what I'm not
really willing to pick sides I'm just
wanting to know I don't want to be I
don't want to sound like I'm being ugly
or you know you're not what you're
asking is for for better for worse for
richer for poorer unto thee all my
worldly goods I pledge okay okay that is
a good spiritual foundation for a
marriage and when you try to do a joint
venture instead of a marriage that's
when everything gets screwed up and
that's that's where people get into all
kinds of problems so I think you're
right on track hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and say you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
[Music]